but we continue this half-hour with a
test of wills between Congress and the
White House next week House Democrats
will vote on a resolution to block
President Trump's national emergency
declaration to build a border wall
this comes as at least 16 states are
already challenging his declaration as
unconstitutional some of the strongest
legal pushback is coming from a group of
landowners in South Texas who were among
the first to file a lawsuit against the
president Mireya Villarreal spoke to
some of them along the us-mexico border
did you get up there and and paint this
yourself
I sure did how long did it take you
about 40 minutes took off my shoes and
they say here we go NIDA Alvarez is
sending a clear message her family has
owned this property along the banks of
the Rio Grande River in South Texas for
more than 30 years it's now at risk of
being taken away by the government for a
new border wall so she's suing the Trump
administration to keep it this property
is my life it is my home this is where
my family gets together this is my
family it is my heritage you know what
am I going to do if I don't have a home
and we will have a national emergency
and we will then be sued the only
statement released by the Department of
Defense so far says the national
emergency declaration authorizes the
Secretary of Defense to determine
whether border barriers are necessary I
hope it's a wake-up call for all
Americans that this administration that
purports to be all about law and order
is in fact lawless Mariana Trevino
Wright is the executive director of the
national butterfly center a facility
that could lose about 70 acres of land a
lawsuit they filed back in 2017
to stop the wall was recently dismissed
is there a fear that that this might be
what's in store for other landowners I
think it's a very real possibility all
that is his mother who lives right next
door is in hospice care for cancer so
for this family there's no other choice
but to fight does it feel like a David
and Goliath situation yes it does it
is because I'm just an average citizen
that does not have the power the
authority that mr. Trump has it is very
hard I am fighting two battles one that
I know for a fact I am going to lose and
that is the one with my mother the other
one there is hope there is hope for
tomorrow if we go with the laws of the
United States we have a chance for CBS
this morning Saturday media via al in
South Texas Wow those personal stories
inside this larger issue that sometimes
get forgotten but write that one story
for her it's so important yeah and it's
very scary when you come up against the
US government yes it is
eminent domain formidable foe